[Musique]
c'est le terroir c'est le soleil c'est
l'expression des jeunes de notre pays
les asini cij a autant d'importance que
le soleil se veulent contrôler ça et
première rencontre au premier contact de
personne n'a vraiment jamais
stress intense très jolie oui c'est plus
trop quoi ça sert un de nos gens sans
rien ne vous choque pas c'est normal
et vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous des lacs sont ici et pourquoi vous
ai dit si oui pourquoi pas ce que je dis
parmi des gens qui ne l'ont pas puisque
on lave tous les vaccins alors c'est au
26 avenue garibaldi
non alors vous prenez c'est un mot -
c'est dans la partie haute de la ville
le fait d'avoir ce qu'on appelle un
accent est absolument tirer des miroirs
est certain que lorsque j'étais jeune
comédien que j'ai ambitionner de jouer
des rôles importants
on m'a fait remarquer à maintes reprises
c'est que une fois ci je ne perdais pas
cet accent méridional
il était exclu pour moi d'envisager quoi
que ce soit d'autre que des petits rôles
et alors en plus c'était des rôles de
personnages ou des gendarmes assez
grotesque ou des concierges du midi ou
des bougnats des ti bafin des trucs où
il ya quinze lignes à 10 on n'aime pas
des fois où c'est une véritable
caricature des gens du midi qu'elle il
est vrai que chaque fois qu'on veut
représenter un personnage un peu con
disons le mot souvent avec un accent un
l'habit ne fait pas lemoine les gens
sont tellement habitués à fonctionner la
poissonnière l'accent du midi
coco chanel c'est l'accent pointu
forcément ça laisse des traces et même
inconsciemment ça laisse des traces
y compris chez nous chaque fois qu'on a
r à des gens que l'on ne connaît pas
chaque fois que l'on a à faire un
téléphone chaque fois qu'on a à faire un
quelconque objet qui peut symboliser le
pouvoir ou quelque chose qui se
rapproche on a automatiquement un petit
peu on se refait la façade on rectifie
la position on remet la cravate un petit
peu mieux et automatiquement on peut
être un petit peu sur l'accent mais
puisque jeudi à paris tout de même faut
savoir que derrière une accent qu'on
appelle lui me dit bon il d'abord il ya
de multiples accents ce provence du
languedoc ceux de gascogne est derrière
tous ces accents il y à une seule et
même culture qui remonte aux troubadours
qui est une culture prestigieuse et
qu'il n'a pas du tout à rougir ni de sa
langue ni de son accent alors c'est vrai
que la langue a été presque éliminé
complètement de de cette zone
linguistique du sud de la france mais
ils restent encore cet accent est
aujourd'hui après avoir fait la chasse
au patois ont fait la chasse souvent aux
accents comme une ultime une ultime
course a vraiment éliminer éradiquer
complètement 7 7 langues maudite nous
avions une prof en primaire qui nous
disait que l'accent provençal c'est un
accent vulgaire il nous obliger à parler
avec les mêmes comme ça l'accent frenchy
à part quelques exceptions il ya très
très peu de dax en disons du midi même
si ça recouvre beaucoup de beaucoup
d'accent différents mais il y en a très
peu alors qu'il ya énormément de gens
que ce soit de la politique ou du show
business qui sont issus des régions
dites méridionale alors c'est vécu par
beaucoup justement quand même comme un
handicap comme un obstacle c'est vrai
c'est vrai pourtant ça semble étonnant
puisque les
de même des rois de france je pense à un
ré 4 avait plus que l'accent puisque 80
des difficultés à s'exprimer en français
donc si c'est vrai c'est étonnant mais
c'est comme ça il semblerait qu'il y ait
eu un parcours du combattant vers le
pouvoir où il faudrait se mouler pour
arriver pour arriver à cela se
grandirait combien de gens du d'ailleurs
on trouvait le moyen de dire oh le mec
du midi ils sont aujourd'hui trop car tu
ils foutent rien est ce que je sais pas
si c'est dans ces eaux roma russe ou
famille où il ya cette fameuse partie de
cartes envoie charpin qui est patron
d'une grosse entreprise qui est toujours
là avec m a vu un mec un pdg passer sa
journée au bistrot ses fonctions
disparaît dans les classes ou alors je
m'habitue et je ne l'entend plus c'est
pas et s'il disparaît à votre avis c'est
pourquoi uniformisation est la langue
régionale disparaît l'action disparaît
les murs de béton sont partout les mêmes
et je crois que c'est l'uniformisation
et c'est ce qu'il faudrait un petit peu
éviter peut-être c'est jose quelque part
il ya un reniement et ça doit pas se
faire sans quelques problèmes au niveau
psychologique c'est évident je crois que
ça a été vraiment très intériorisée trop
intériorisée par les gens du midi de la
france et leurs goûts leurs parents et
leurs grands-parents ont tellement eu à
souffrir de des moqueries inhérentes à
cet accent que e.on faire un certain
nombre d'entre eux ont décidé de le
perdre et ceux qui n'y sont pas parvenu
parce qu'il est très difficile
quelquefois d'arriver comme ça à se
débarrasser d'une partie aussi
importante de ces personnels de sa
personnalité ceux qui n'y sont pas
parvenus on dit quelquefois du mal à
ouvrir la bouche ou bien et seil
concernant de rectifier leur accent son
jeune et qu'elle paraissait c'est un peu
c'est vrai que c'est très très très
embêtant c'est toujours la même chose en
province on ne veut rien savoir
j'ai des obligations à madaoui bien sûr
[Musique]